hello hi I'm sorry did I surprise you I
was surprised by your presence but
that's fine welcome to the monitor again
hopefully a repeat viewer is always on
Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired this
week what do we have we have a couple of
great instrumental albums that have
dropped we have a couple of well one
comic book and one kind of incredible
comic ish graphic project that dropped
but first we have the return of Homeland
on Showtime if you watch the emmys I'm
sure you know that season one racked up
the gold and buy gold I mean the gold
leaf covered guilted but probably
underneath brass trophies notably for
Damian Lewis and Claire Danes leap or
trails Damian Lewis if you did not watch
season one last year as a US Marine who
is a poww and is now back and has
converted to Islam and has become
somewhat of a sleeper agent for a mmm
let's just calm a terrorist a guy in the
middle east to kind of is puppeteering
strings or controlling the strings as a
puppeteer at any rate he is controlling
kind of damian lewis is agenda Claire
Danes as a mentally unstable and vastly
entertaining CIA agent who was kind of
kicked out of the agency at the end of
season one sorry retroactively spoiler
alert but they are both back in in fine
form they both have this just amazing
these great moments of kind of
jaw-dropping intensity especially Damian
Lewis who was able to channel all the
blood flow into his face and
specifically in his eyeballs so that you
think they're just going to pop right
out of the skull and Claire Danes has a
moment in episode 1 which first aired on
sunday night which is just so off the
rocker as far as insanity goes that I
that I don't even want to spoil it for
you but you will know when you see it it
is near the end of the episode at any
rate because it started on Sunday night
and Showtime as one of those premium
cable networks they are playing it all
week long episode 2 starts sunday night
but got plenty of time to catch up so
make sure you check that out back to you
ok thank you why you ask am i standing
in
of an enormous lotus flower am I
achieving nirvana perhaps but more
because flying lotus his new album is
out this week until the quiet comes it
is his fourth album he brings back
Erykah Badu and thunder cast and some
other people that he's worked with in
the past really really nice record I
mean is there are some moments of kind
of not a tonality but there's certainly
percussively jarring if you will some
kind of stuttery things but there are
also some like really smooth out nice
moments things that wouldn't been out of
place say 20 years ago but have been
updated I'd you know it's for for a nice
kind of instrumental intent experience
but it is not the only one like that I
want to also give a shout to a hurricane
season in Brooklyn which is an album
that actually came out last week from
analog player society and I want to kind
of give that a little equal billing
alongside the Flying Lotus album analog
player society is a group of session
musicians in Brooklyn that have all been
kind of brought together to create this
record and it is it's kind of a surprise
was kind of a sleeper experience for me
some people like to compare them to
vampire weekend in the sense that they
kind of bring quote world music into
into pop music I don't exactly know that
means I do know that a lot of the cuts
on the album have kind of a reggae
little to them they definitely play with
that the with a little bit of one drop
in a little bit of shuffle beats but
there's a kind of really entertaining
cover of i can't wait the old freestyle
80's song by new shoes with with some
great female vocals on it she kind of
sketch our ass off on it but it's it's a
really upbeat album which kind of is a
nice counterpart to the Flying Lotus
which is a lot more down tempo and
low-key so Flying Lotus until the quiet
comes and analog player society
hurricane season in Brooklyn two new
albums one brand new this week the other
new from last week both worth a listen
make sure you pick those up back to you
okay thanks for that let's talk about
comics first off happy number one which
started last week it is Grant Morrison's
new four-issue miniseries it's always
nice when the craziest person in comic
writing comes back and it is detailed
very quickly of kind of your your
typical alcoholic ex-detective has all
kinds of issues including mental turned
hit man and he has stumbled on to this
kind of mob fortune and now he is on the
run from the mob and he is also
hallucinating or so he thinks this crazy
cartoon blue horse who purports to be
someone else's imaginary friend and is
trying to lead him to safety it is
ridiculous and it has one of the most
hilariously disturbing panels that I've
seen all year I can't really describe it
because this is a family show but trust
me when I say when you see it you will
know what I am talking about it involves
dressing up like some sort of an insect
and engaging in some sort of act of love
let's leave it at that so that is one of
the comic things to check out for and
the other is this what is this this is
building stories which is Chris where's
new project it's out this week if you
read some of building stories that
appeared almost a decade ago in New York
Times Sunday magazine he had this kind
of cereal a comic strip I guess is the
only way to describe it that sounds
really patronizing but I don't mean it
to be that involved that kind of
followed the denizens of this building
but what's incredible about this it is
actually a collection it is an endless
collection you know you got bits here
you gotta strip you've got a book here
you've got you've got like a dungeon
master screen which involves the
building itself it's it's all these
different forms of storytelling and
there's really no beginning and there's
no end it's just kind of meant for you
to pick up things and read them and
experience them in any kind of order you
choose as such it has this kind of a
temper ality that is at the same time
weirdly life like it's a voyeuristic
kind of experience but it's it's all the
best for it Chris we're kind of nails
quiet despair and sadness in a way that
kind of resonates with me I found myself
on the verge of tears pretty often
reading as stuff
and so far in this that is that has
definitely happened so this is a this is
definitely not your average for dollar
weekly comic purchase but building
stories by Chris where it is out this
week and it is well worth the pick up if
you feel like making the investment but
that's it for the monitor this week
please email us at the monitor at
wired.com any suggestions love criticism
etc etc we will be back next week with
more pop culture goodness but until then
inspirational catchphrase here